i'm delighted to speak at such a
wonderful celebration of the teaching
profession
as unesco special envoy for peace and
reconciliation
i believe that education is on the front
line of making peace happen
between and within communities in this
respect
teachers always bring more the knowledge
and skills they open the minds and
hearts of our children
they create an awareness that the future
can always be a better place
and they do this every day most of this
work goes unnoticed because
teachers puts their students in the
spotlight
for me the global teacher prize is an
inspirational idea because it turns that
spotlight
and shines it on the unsung heroes who
teach in the classrooms
all around the world teachers like our
top 10 finalists here tonight
this year during the pandemic we have
seen the biggest disruption
to education in history and yet we have
seen teachers go above and beyond to
keep the world's children
learning today we will honor
one very special teacher i'm delighted
to announce that the global teacher
prize
covet hero award goes to jamie frost
from the united kingdom
jamie your internationally acclaimed
website for math tuition
dr frost mass has had over 7 million
resource downloads and is making
fun for children all over the world
especially during the pandemic
your creativity and dedication have
illuminated millions of minds for free
thank you jamie thank you to all the
world's teachers